salamualikum' greetings of peace I'm
excited to bring you another exciting
episode of the D show with another
exciting guest now Islamophobes have no
compunction hiding under the pretence of
free speech which is actually hate
speech while going on a bigoted hate
fuelled witch-hunt against Muslims and
Islam while my next guest get this my
next guest was fired from his university
job as a professor for critical thinking
and asking some of the 6y questions and
what are those 6y questions well we will
be discussing and asking those same
questions with you today and let you be
the judge and we'll also be trying to
get to the bottom of why did Alex Jones
take a turn and all of a sudden start
attacking Islam all this involves my
next guest dr. Kevin when we come back
[Music]
[Music]
we got a very special guest in the
studio here I'm excited to bring on the
show I'm going to be talking about some
really interesting things here with dr.
Kevin how are you sir
hey it's good to be with you Eddie thank
you for being with us
yeah well it's wonderful to be in your
show I've seen seen your show for years
going back and it's great what you're
doing thank you very much thank you can
you tell us how did you get into you've
written a lot of books you got into an
area that many people would think is you
know there's labels people call people
conspiracy theories you know they make
them look like they're crazy whatever
the case anyone who questions anything
of an official story it's like okay
whatever the media puts out there you
got a swallow was that hook bait and
sinker all right and anyone questions
anything but your question you went down
some rabbit holes I've gone down all of
rabbit hole yeah it took me a while yeah
I started going down rabbit holes when I
was what 16 17 years old and discovered
that the JFK assassination
was a coup d'etat in the United States I
realized that American democracy was not
quite what we were being told it was and
that didn't completely change my life
overnight I still went through a normal
kind of academic career track looking to
be a first and English teacher French
teacher humanities teacher and then I
came to Islam in 1993 and decided to
learn Arabic so I got into my PhD
program and I was planning to be just
kind of a normal professor but after
9/11 a couple years after 9/11 actually
at the end of 2003
I looked into 9/11 closer after hearing
that David Ray Griffin was working on it
and saying it was an inside job and so I
looked at that evidence and
was convinced and realized that this was
so important that it was worth pursuing
and so I've been jumping down all the
rabbit holes ever since why was it so
important
well this launched a new era not only in
American politics but in in the world
politics as well you know we're now
living through the so-called clash of
civilizations which is basically a war
on Islam and as Muslims we know that we
are obliged to stand up for what's right
you know to enjoin the good and forbid
the bad to speak truth to power to
follow the example of prophet muhammad
peace upon him he and his companions
we're in a much more difficult situation
than we are today they were under
oppression by an Oleg our key that was
mistreating people and that's the real
example of Islam if the ethical level
and I felt obliged to follow that I
couldn't see myself spending seven years
on the career track keeping my mouth
shut about this so I started speaking
out and all hell broke loose so you are
a how can you define your career at that
time where you Albury at that time oh I
would have been in my 40s I guess so
you're a university professor no I just
finished my PhD in 2004 actually so I
actually was just as I was finishing the
PhD that I discovered this 9/11 evidence
yeah and it was it was bad timing
because normally you have to spend about
seven years pursuing tenure before you
feel like you have any job security but
I couldn't see keeping my mouth shut for
seven years yeah so were these some of
that these are called like this six whys
we'll get right into that and I want to
go into some history because you're also
a historian well I've become a sort of a
an amateur historian my training is not
so much in history I've been trained in
journalism languages and literature
humanities and area studies in to some
extent religious studies but all of that
of course is all tied in with history so
I've been looking at what you might call
hidden history on the last decade or so
because many people are in the same
we're in the same position because they
know after because Islam is the fastest
growing way of life in the world
accordingly
Guinness Book of World Records many
people they connect with it it makes
sense and they go down that real rabbit
hole and they find out wow is llama
answers all the questions for the
purpose of life why am I here where am I
going would I die it's a peaceful way of
life it calls for you know so many great
things and to have it you know
attributed to to someone of the worst
things in American history we take
strong offense to that so it was at a
catalyst where you took off to to see
like hold on where could some some any
any person get you know the audacity to
try to use Islam and to justify such an
evil act yeah I guess I saw that what
the authorities are saying about Islam
and the reality of Islam is very very
different and so that that's I guess by
coming to Islam and seeing that that
opened me up to going one step further
and saying well if they can lie about
Islam if they lie about JFK and these
other events that I've learned about
it's possible they could be lying about
9/11 but honestly for two years I didn't
realize that they could have done
something that outdate audacious now I
figured it was something relatively
minor maybe they steered and infiltrated
these hijackers or something but the
whole the whole 9/11 story never really
made sense to me but I just didn't get
into looking really closely at it for
two years and I feel really stupid about
that how could I have been sleepwalking
for two years actually believing this
official story most of my Muslim friends
in Madison Wisconsin didn't believe it
from the get-go I was the only one who
said well let's wait and see how the
evidence shakes out but yeah you're
right that if any of us who've actually
looked into Islam and seen this
completely different picture the reality
of Islam which as you say it's it's the
best preserved authentic tradition of
the divine revelations that have been
sent down it's well preserved and it
offers essentially perfect guidance
anybody in the world who practices Islam
can have their spiritual level uplifted
and seeing that seeing that it clears up
the misconceptions of the earlier brands
of monotheism by giving us the true
oneness of God by telling us that these
are all mess
have come and brought God's Word all
these different people and here's a way
of life that simple straightforward
makes sense has profound ethical
implications and essentially really
straightens people out and straighten
societies out to the extent that it's
actually practiced in all of that is so
different from what we're fed in the
media that yeah it's another rabbit hole
as well yeah what do you think about
this term when people as soon as you
question you have we're going to get
into some questions they're just
questions that that should be addressed
I think but when you're called or have
you ever been called conspiracy theorist
have I ever not been called a conspiracy
theorist I got paid a dollar for every
time I've been called a conspiracy
theorist I'd be a rich man now there are
people who you know they come out with
some crazy no theories conspiracy I'm
not one of them
I but there's questions and I'm going to
get into some questions are very
important but what do you think of the
term when someone just throw as soon as
you ask a question someone will label
your conspiracy theories well that's a
thought stopper what they're saying is
we don't want to even think about what
you're talking about so here's a way to
not think about it and interestingly
enough this blood stopper was invented
by the CIA there was an actual CIA memo
that was sent out to all of the CIA's
assets in American journalism and world
journalism in the mid-1960s and it
ordered their assets to start calling
the people who were investigating the
JFK assassination quote-unquote
conspiracy theorists that's where the
term comes from
so the conspiracy theory about the term
conspiracy theory is one of the many
conspiracy theories that are actually
true so if someone called you a
conspiracy theories which they have
these do agree to that terms you know
I'm not a conspiracy - what do you
thought I would say I'm a conspiracy
realist now the most commonly prosecuted
federal crime at E is conspiracy the
federal government admits with that
there are conspiracies all over the
place and they prosecute a few of them
so we all know that conspiracies exist a
conspiracy is simply more than one
person who working to accomplish
something that's illegal or unethical
happens all the time look around folks
so this the term conspiracy theory aliy
makes no sense at all it was used with
the JFK assassination to question those
denied that one guy Lee Harvey Oswald
did it it was more than one guy but
today it makes no sense with 9/11 we all
know more than one guy did it
the official conspiracy theory holds
that it was 19 guys with box cutters led
not just guys 19 pork chop loving
whiskey drinking cocaine snorting
stripper dating crate crazed you know
cocaine freaks to patronize Jack
Abramoff Scecina votes and kept flying
to Las Vegas for gambling junket but
they were also radical Muslim
fundamentalist that's the official story
those 19 guys led by a man on kidney
dialysis in a cave in Afghanistan Osama
bin Laden somehow caused three buildings
to vaporize at freefall acceleration
using box cutters that's the official
conspiracy theory it is a conspiracy
theory it posits a conspiracy of at
least 20 people and that conspiracy
theory is one of the craziest conspiracy
theories that's ever been promulgated
well is in there a new poll or there are
several polls that most Americans now
over 50% some as high as 80 85 percent
don't believe the official story
yeah the polls are kind of all over the
place depending on how you ask but
there's one very clear poll from 2006
it's a Scripps poll that found that 36
percent of Americans said it was likely
that 9/11 was an inside job designed to
trigger the wars in Afghanistan and Iraq
so 36 percent of the American people
that's over a hundred million people who
say that and there's another poll that
shows that something was an eighty four
eighty five percent of the American
people don't fully believe the
government's version yeah you know Alex
Jones oh yeah do I ever I was in his
studio once you were yeah why did he
take a turn and I wasn't a big fan of
always watching him but I sometimes
someone would send me something and I'd
take a look and he'd bring up some
interesting points but recently he
started really going after Islam yeah
why did he do that well it's a totally
turn in another direction there are two
theories about this and I don't know
which is right or maybe neither but the
two efford one is there's a whole school
thought that emphasizes that Alex
Jones has always been kind of covering
up for Israel now let's face it Eddie I
know this is very controversial and
people are going to throw rotten fruit
at us when we say this but making Islam
the great new civilizational enemy to
replace communism really did benefit the
state of Israel tremendously because it
United the whole West against the people
who were the biggest problem for Israel
and it led to wars against the very
countries that were giving Israel a hard
time so Alex was talking about 9/11 not
being what we were told but he has
always steered the conversation away
from discussing that aspect of the case
so there's some folks to think there's
something funny going on there and they
point out that you know there's a lawyer
who is the same lawyer as people in the
Bronfman crime family which is the the
Jewish Zionist crime family that
dominates Canada so that's one theory
and I don't know if that's true or not
another and I think possibly more
plausible reason that Alex Jones would
have gone down this crazy path of
extreme Islamophobia even though he
noticed 9/11 was an inside job is that
he makes more money that way because
remember he's looking for the biggest
possible audience he's selling snake oil
and he doesn't really want a smart
sophisticated audience he wants a pretty
dumb gullible audience so what's the
best way to get a bunch of dumb gullible
people who don't really believe what
they hear in the mainstream media to
watch your show well bash Islam because
there are a lot of people who are not
know that maybe they don't have a time
maybe they don't have the intellect
maybe they don't have whatever to really
look into things and they like to look
at the screen and like you know excited
and they don't quite believe the
mainstream media those people are wide a
wide open audience and some somebody
like Alex can build a huge audience of
this bottom-feeders basically added add
them to the more sophisticated people
who've been watching him especially
since back when he was doing reasonably
good stuff when he had Curtin MO working
with him so anyway he's gotten much much
worse he's focusing on a much lower
level audience and it's really
unfortunate because his operation has
done some good stuff over the years
they're used to anyone okay so you've
been on this show oh yeah yeah so you
had a have you tried to reach out to him
ever since he went on this is long as
llama phobia of bashing have you tried
to rewrite I tried a few times and I
tried many times and there's actually a
guy here in Chicago who kind of knows
Alex or was communicating with Alex a
bit and I tried to go through him and
then I tried to be you know when he
ignored me then I you know I started
being a little more critical and in the
last couple of years he's gotten so bad
that I've given up trying to be nice to
him and I basically you know call it the
way I see it yeah we're going to go
ahead and take a break and we'll be
right back with more here with dr. Kevin
Derek back here on the Dean show dr.
Kevin thank you again for being with us
so we were talking about Alex Jones and
how we kind of took off and you know
join the hate parade of instigating all
this hate against Islam and Muslims
you're Muslim yourself and you know what
it stands for and it's totally the
antithesis of you know what people are
saying out there and if somebody would
be sincerely and genuinely looking into
it they would come to the same
conclusion that we have but many people
they just join that hate parade it's
like easier and Alex I'm really sad that
he joined that and he's still getting a
lot of Miss information and you've
reached out to him you tried because I
think that would be genuine on his part
to bring almost unlike yourself bring
someone we've also we made a program I
mean a friend of mine dr. Sabeel and we
actually invited him to invite the
Muslims on come if you have some some
questions and some doubts about
something some misinformation bring us
on but we also hit a dead end yeah it's
too bad he's a Christian
we identifies as a Christian and his
audience is mostly Christian and I 9/11
was largely designed to cause strife
between Christians and Muslims and to
make both groups look bad yeah and to
try to make the atheist look good you
know suddenly we had all of these
best-selling books of the New Atheists
because of 9/11 and really Christians
and Muslims should be working together
and and really the good Christians and
Muslims are working together now but
it's really sad when somebody with that
huge audience of
mostly Christians who don't really
believe the official story of everything
gets misled by Alex Jones and you know
there are some good conservative
Christians who are reaching out to Islam
and were telling the truth about Islam
people like mark still gender have you
ever had him on your show no I would
highly recommend that he's a former
congressman a very conservative
Christian there's all murmur Islamophobe
okay he was at yeah I I met him once I
believe he's a great guy and and he's a
conservative Christian with an accurate
view of Islam it's such people do exist
okay he goes into the Semitic languages
and defines really what the word Allah
how it's their Muslim is that the same
yeah yeah yeah and guy and basically
what he found out is that the Quran is
closer to real Christianity than most
Christians understanding of Christianity
and why is that well it's because if you
get if you actually study the languages
you find out that the original Aramaic
that Jesus spoke contains words or
they're cognates of the same terms we
find in Quran so the Quranic message and
Jesus's message as best as it can be
reconstructed through these Greek texts
which were translations from the Aramaic
it's it they're ultimately very similar
and still gender recognize that it's so
important and that actually vouches for
the authenticity of both revelations
yeah
then this also happened back in in Rome
and you discussed this mural then he
tried to set up and he did set up the
Christians and they were persecuted
because there was an attack that he did
can you elaborate on it was one of those
us yeah false flag was on history's
first big false Flags a Nero burned Rome
and blamed the Christians and we've had
a couple of other of these big false
flags aimed at religious groups too
the other really big one that stands out
is the Gunpowder Plot of 1605 I think it
was Guy Fawkes was a Catholic agitator
who was set up as the Patsy with a bunch
of gunpowder in wet gunpowder and
barrels and he was placed beneath
Parliament and they arrested him and
claimed that he was going to blow up the
Parliament kill all the top government
people in England and this message
against Catholics went out to all the
churches in the Church of England and it
was a lot like 9/11 except that instead
of TV screens this was preachers in
churches screaming about the evil
Catholic plot to blow up our
governments and so this was the the
Gunpowder Plot was the false flag that
launched the British Empire by whipping
up hatred against Catholics and causing
England to go to war basically
permanently with Catholic Spain and
Portugal steal all of their colonies
ultimately and and the British Empire
was the result now
what were your mentioning the the Nero
what I brought up and then this the
Gunpowder Plot and we'll bring up some
more are these established facts now
this is where historians are people have
uncovered this anything I'm going to be
very skeptical because I'm sure there
are some things that are very
controversial debatable but when we talk
about these IDs without a shadow of a
doubt things like let's bring up one
Northwoods okay yeah well things that we
can bring up its crystal clear there's
no arguing over it near Nero burning
Rome and women Christians I think that's
pretty much majority opinion that's
majority of enya Gunpowder Plot being a
false flag yeah and that is not so much
because that's the official myth of the
British Empire the official version that
the evil Catholic guy did it yeah it was
trying to blow up Parliament so that
hasn't fully been accepted by but I
think that more and more historians have
seen that that that that was a false or
something were eight ninety percent
where it's not how about northwards
North Woods is pretty much assure well I
we have the documents yeah and the only
reason we have these documents which
proved that the top level of the United
States government and military were
planning to basically attack America
they tell us for people who don't know
what Norwood Northwoods in the plot
behind that right well this was in 1962
and the hardliners in the US military
were looking for an excuse to go to war
with Cuba
yeah so the Joint Chiefs of Staff
America's highest military commanders
led by a man and general Lyman Lemnitzer
drafted a plan that would have involved
sinking American ships must killing
American sailors on the high seas it
would have involved bombing American
cities and killing innocent American
civilians and it would have involved a
fake airliner ship down blamed on fidel
castro and all of this would have led to
a u.s. invasion of Cuba but President
Kennedy and his advisor Robert McNamara
apparently said no to it so that is we
know that existed because
we have the official document somebody
saved McNamara's copy apparently it was
discovered by an Australian researcher
in the 1990s after it was released under
the JFK official Records Act and then it
became very well-known interestingly
right about the time of 9/11
what about gulf of tonkin again that's
another well one thing everybody agrees
on with the gulf of tonkin was that what
really happened and what was reported
were completely different that was the
supposed north vietnamese attack on an
American ship that launched the big
American escalation in Vietnam however
all historians today admit that there
was no such attack so the only question
is what really happened there was maybe
a little bit of a skirmish with the
North Vietnamese boat and then there was
a big American boat was firing into the
sea basically this was then reported as
if it were a serious attack by the North
Vietnamese all historians agree that it
wasn't are there any other incidences
that that we're getting one story it's
like if you if you have someone now that
you want to trust but the person is
coming out you know through their
actions untrustworthy so you find out
they lied to you once it's again they
lie to you Yuki I mean you just quite
you just blindly accept everything he's
telling or you're going to be really
skeptical you follow me you're not going
to conjure up okay I'm not conjuring up
some theories it but I'm just asking
questions so another one I think Pearl
Harbor right that's one that's still
debated that's the best so we won't okay
if you want to get into that well I'm
not just briefly briefly the argument is
that Pearl Harbor which turned American
opinion around upside down and brought
the u.s. into World War two prior to
Pearl Harbor 80 plus percent of the
American people didn't want to get into
World War two and then there was a huge
Japanese sneak attack out of Pearl
Harbor Hawaii that killed two thousand
plus American sailors and gave us these
amazing images of ships blowing up they
look a lot like 9/11 and the official
version of that is that it was just a
Japanese sneak attack but the almost
certain reality which historians may be
you know a third to a half of the
Astoria pnes probably would admit this
at least privately now and the rest
would be like this was this was
orchestrated there was an eight-point
plan in the
Rosabelle administration to force the
Japanese to strike the first blow and
Roberts tenets and his book day of
deceit has shown quite conclusively in
my opinion that the Americans knew
exactly when and where the Japanese were
coming intentionally sent their aircraft
carriers out to sea because we needed
those that were militarily important and
left a bunch of mothballed battleships
in the harbor with men on them as a
target to be destroyed so essentially
the American side sacrificed 2,000
sailors
to rouse American public opinion into
into the state of fury that would allow
entrance into World War two here's one
for you I think this is undebatable it's
proven how about the invasion of Iraq
based on a lie
and it's proven now nobody is going to
debate this right that there was weapons
of mass destruction what about that one
even President Trump got a lot of
mileage with that one of hashing Jorge
agent George W Bush and knocking him out
of the presidential race everybody
admits that there was no significant WMD
now there may have been some old
mothball WMT that they're active
actually lied about and covered up so
that's a whole different kettle of fish
here and another one the first Iraq
where the Gulf War first Gulf War was
sold to Congress thanks to this bizarre
lie in which a public relations firm
called Hill and Knowlton which is close
to the Bush family produced the Kuwaiti
ambassador's daughter and she posed as a
nurse nurse nasarah from a Kuwaiti
hospital she went on television and in
front of Congress and told us that the
evil Iraqi soldiers had been grabbing
poor innocent Kuwaiti babies from their
incubators in the hospital where she
worked and bashing their brains out on
the floor that was the story that
enraged American public opinion and sold
that war to Congress and of course it
wasn't really a Kuwaiti nurse it wasn't
him dasa ters daughter people started
saying wait a minute isn't that the
ambassador's daughter and so it was
exposed fairly quickly and yet no but
they didn't tell everybody that we see a
lot of fake things around us you have
you know fake food okay you have a lot
of this thing I talk about a lot now you
know nutrition because you have a lot of
fake food you have a lot of fake stories
people making up conjuring things
Botox fake dis fake that you know and
then why is this hard to believe that
you know these because there's also
reports that came out not too long ago
of the Pentagon paying over half of I
mean billion dollars to a PR firm to
create fake terrorist videos right I saw
that that was one of these dozens and
dozens and dozens of false flag stories
that we report on over at false flag
weekly news and that's also well
documented that's not one that anybody's
arguing didn't happen so the idea that
terrorism is being used clandestinely
and even the spectacle of terrorism when
maybe there isn't even real terrorism in
some cases is being used to manipulate
public opinion it really should be a
no-brainer but because we're just
pummeled incessantly with the mainstream
version of things people have been
brainwashed into being afraid to even go
there I mean we I have to admit in every
you know bag of apples you got some
rotten ones you do have some lunatics
that you know might attribute themselves
to being Muslim you know but anyone I
like whose sincerely practicing Islam
and sees what it stands for these are
the things that really agitate and
aggravates you when you you know really
what Islam is about and then you have to
keep defending it against these things
that potentially don't have even even if
even if all the Muslims were doing
create drinking alcohol for instance or
eating pork or being in just Islam calls
to be just Aslam calls to stay away from
evil so you can't blame Islam is right
as a good example you probably know if
the drunk driver crashes the Mercedes
Benz you can't blame the manufacturer
right for the drunk driver right but now
we're going above and beyond and we're
saying hold on you will many truth
seekers out there who are going down
these rabbit holes are seeing like hold
on there's even more here right when you
start to uncover the the history and we
see that in previous time certain things
have been uncovered then this thing half
a billion dollars on a PR firm fake
videos terrorists I mean to do what -
what's that all about well it's it's
even worse than that
that was one example but the isn't it
bizarre that the public relations agency
that handles Isis videos is run by Rita
Katz the Israeli intelligence agent it's
called site Intelligence Group si te and
it's a Mossad spin-off so it's basically
an Israeli operation and yet we're told
that essentially every Isis video that
is released goes through site
Intelligence Group now many of these
have been proven fake you know over and
over and over in fact recent leaders we
discovered that one of the worst
supposed Muslim terrorists in the whole
world
a guy named Australian Asst supposedly
operated online turned out to be none
other than Joshua Goldberg the suspect
rather that federal investigators
stopped from carrying out a terror plot
here in Kansas City this was published
in The Sydney Morning Herald and they
have been tracking this guy online
Joshua Goldberg a young Jewish men
operating out of his basement in Florida
who's been impersonating evil Muslim
terrorists and evil white supremacist
and people like that all over the world
just like this new guy in Israel kadar
that was just arrested and Israeli
teenager has faced court accused of
targeting Victorian schools with hoax
bomb and shooting threats he's alleged
to have made more than 2,000 calls as
part of a worldwide campaign to spread
fear and alarmed Michael Qaeda is
accused of spreading terror across the
globe for thousands and thousands of
threats against Jewish community centers
was actually in a Jewish Israeli kid a
young man whose uncle was a high up guy
in Israeli black operations intelligence
so we we've seen so many of these cases
and but one of the things that really
aggravates me the most is that they
blame this on radical Islam on
supposedly the more pious the Muslim the
more dangerous and this is the exact
opposite of the truth even if we
accepted the official story of let's say
9/11 then it's these guys were not pious
they the people that were told were the
nineteen hijackers there may have been
some identity theft there I don't know
but they were you know their behavior
was the least Islamic that you could
have
imagine and then that same pattern
repeats itself over and over and over in
so many of these cases the patsies were
blamed for the suppose of radical
Islamic attacks are people with
radically Una's Lama Clive Styles
there's stories you can't believe the
mastermind of the Paris attacks in
November 2015 was in a car so that he
was smooth a were all drinking and
smoking big joints and they got pulled
over as they were fleeing the scene of
the crime heading to Belgium I think it
was and the cops just let him go and
wave them on and and so what we're
seeing these cases over and over to
these Patsy's the the supposed radical
Muslims were set up to take the blame
for these things are marginal characters
they're kind of lowlife characters often
from Muslim backgrounds but very rarely
serious Muslims and they get involved
with organized crime drug trafficking
the corrupt side of the police
establishment the intelligence
establishment they get manipulated and
they get set up I think now we're going
to take a break but we can get past ad
hominem attacks many people start you
know attacking the person who's wants to
bring up questions but I think now we've
proved something that okay we can't
trust this person whoever is bringing
these claims we thought showing some
examples through history and then we
gave the big example of the just
outright lie of you know that Bush with
the whole weapons of mass destruction
which over two million innocent people
over spend a 10 years were killed we
should be a right have a right to ask
some very important questions without
being labeled you know whatever label I
think is that a fair assumption but I
would make all its common sense and we
have some why some of the top will come
the top six why's that have to do with
what we're talking about because that
was a catalyst this evil event that
Islam condemns Muslims condemned 9/11
and we're going to be asking the six
why's with five special guests here dr.
Kevin when we come back don't go
anywhere
back here with dr. Kevin Barrett the
wise mouth are you ready
why are over 2500 these are not just
laymen these are people who specialize
in in architecture engineers scientists
mathematicians you know professionals
why are they demanding he's not just
people hanging out in the basement and
they're drinking smoking weed until I
don't believe this official story what's
going on we want to know no these are
these are people the scientists you know
professionals who deal with buildings
and you know explosives or the sciences
the sciences in this area they are
demanding a new investigation why is
that that's right it's 2,500 architects
and engineers and then there are a lot
many many many more scientists on
competence for novel eventually more
than that and the reason that virtually
everybody with any technical expertise
who's looked at what happened in New
York on September 11 2001 is a strong
skeptic of the official version is that
these that what we were told happened
cannot have happened unless the laws of
physics were suspended now as Muslims we
will admit that there there was such a
thing as miracles that there are that's
in our tradition but the idea that these
buildings would be demolished
miraculously with the laws of physics
suspended seems highly unlikely and so
all of these hard-nosed architects
engineers and then these other
scientists are all saying that actually
if you sit them down privately
they'll tell you that the official story
is not just false it's preposterous
the next why is the third building why
does it just fall at freefall speed it
was one of those that does someone who
looks at the tape it didn't even didn't
even get hit no this was building seven
yeah that was the highest security
building in New York it was the CIA's
second biggest headquarters in the world
and it also had the SEC investigations
of Enron all sorts of really serious
secret type stuff and that was also the
command center on the 23rd floor that
was supposed to deal with any emergency
in New York so building seven is 47
story building on the afternoon of 9/11
just boom just
suicide that's the official story just
disappeared in six and a half seconds
straight into its own footprint in an
absolutely classic controlled demolition
may be the most beautiful controlled
demolition ever the professionals in
this area like danny jowenko the leading
european demolition professional was in
awe at the job that these professionals
had done on building seven when he first
was shown this he didn't know it would
happen on 9/11
waha what i thought that's an amazing
demolition they you know these
professionals done a great job they said
it was nine eleven really that what
happened on 9/11 and remember most
people while you still haven't seen much
of this they banned a footage of
building seven coming down from the
major american networks for many years
for at least seven eight years until
they finally were allowed to show it in
2007-2008 because this so-called
collapse of a building never hit by any
planes it was far away from the towers
there were lots of buildings that barely
sustained any damage much closer to the
towers than building 7 was and it took
the government years and years and years
to come up with some ludicrous pretext
for what happened to it so so building
seven is in a lot of ways the Achilles
heel of 9/11 there's really essentially
nobody on earth that's looked seriously
at it that believes that official story
what if someone comes back and says look
that's only 2500 architects engineers
compared that to actually how many
architects and engineers are out there
that aren't yes but why aren't people
coming forward well it's not great for
your career to do that I'm living proof
you know I was on a career track in the
Academy you know I I had the best offer
out of my ph.d program of anybody in the
history of the program Wow University of
California and I turned it down
maybe stupidly I don't know but I you
know my career got blown up for talking
about this and basically everybody know
that's that's sell your free speech huh
there you go yeah you land a land of
freedom somebody hates our freedoms I
don't think it's the Muslims yeah so
these are Kayson engineers don't go
there most of them don't go there the
2500 are the people who are honest and
courageous and they don't care if it's
going to you know get bring them attacks
and career damage but the others all
know if they look at it
the architects and engineers for 9/11
truth has been going to the architects
convention every year and trying to get
them to pass a resolution calling for a
real investigation of what happened to
building seven and they're not having a
whole lot of luck I think they got like
7% the next year they got 20% this year
they get went back to 7% and the reasons
for that were partly the they weren't
given enough time to make their case but
when they went and talked to people who
are voting against it nobody said that
the government is right about building 7
nobody said that they all say oh well
this is this is going to cause our
association problems this happened a
long time ago let's just let sleeping
dogs lie and so on and so forth
so that's the reason that other
professionals don't take it out that has
nothing to do with the truth about what
happened anyone who looked seriously at
it knows the truth which is that it was
a controlled demolition that's
interesting if you you ended up getting
fired I mean you see a lot of
Islamophobes and not many people come
out and they start really like going at
it with the whole free speech and
express but as soon as you express
yourself you ask questions you lose your
job yeah that's right it's a huge double
standard if there's a talker see it is
and if there's a contradiction really in
the heart of this sort of Western
glorification of freedom which is that
you have the freedom to stick with that
ideology and you can talk about freedom
all you want but if you start really
using it to critique the dominant way
that power once you see things then you
get in trouble like the Charlie Hebdo
thing in France was a classic example
remember that where they said these
radical Islamic terrorists shot up this
cartoon magazine and that turned out to
be another false flag I have a book
about that here is called we're not
charlie Abdo and features a lot of very
prominent people including rabbi Michael
Lerner America's most famous politically
active liberal Jew as in the book not
necessarily agreeing with the false flag
interpretation but agreeing that there's
a problem with this whole way propaganda
behind this event and as Charlie Hebdo
thing was all about liberty freedom
right this is the West official ideology
these cartoons should be free to
blaspheme and to say horrible disgusting
seeing things that's that's freedom well
as soon as you question what really
happened there at Charlie Hebdo and you
should question it because there's video
absolute proof that what they claimed
happened couldn't possibly have happened
then you discover the limits of this VBA
or freedom that they're talking about
and it's it's a very sneaky
Orwellian way of you know using words to
mean the opposite of what they really
mean so unfreedom is really what these
people are devoted to but they want you
to lock your mind down yourself they
don't want to have to threaten to throw
you in prison they would rather that you
lock up your own brain if they can train
you to lock up your own brain then they
don't have to spend the month getting
the resources I'm coming and dragging
you off and throwing you in a prison
cell well this is a rabbit hole that I
hadn't gone down I looked into because I
want to really be objective really
looking at things you know from taking
an analytic approach scientific seeing
like okay not coming to try to prove you
know that okay this is you know as a
setup or whatnot but then you just can't
help for instance there's some questions
that that many were asking and I was
repeating them because they were
important with the San Bernadino when
the witnesses and that was one that I
kind of looked into because I wanted to
do a show about it again usually coming
on and saying this has nothing to do
with Islam - guys it's Ramadan he's
supposed to what do you do when you
break if God when we're about these that
were gay yeah he's at he's at he's at a
homosexual bar he's drinking he's doing
everything like these support these 19
guys strip clubs this and that narrow
everything against Islam but now the
witness was they were saying that they
saw multiple sittings witnesses three
white men you're certain that you saw
three men yes but the reason they
believe that there are three individuals
is because witnesses told police that
they saw three men with what appeared to
be long rifles leaving that scene and
they're now looking for a black SUV
right now at work
there was three shooters tall white men
but over here the official story is this
a small young lady that's been born in
December 18 all right yes you know you
went that's what this book is well you
got another one yeah this is this is the
it's called orlando multiply you tell me
about the the three white men did you
hear that yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
multiple witnesses three three sets of
witnesses all saw that the real shooters
in San Bernardino were it wasn't this
couple that they blame with that short
little you know five foot tall 100-pound
Muslim lady it was three large white
paramilitaries that did that shooting is
that Bill McGee can you describe to me
in as much detail as you can what did
the gunman look like I couldn't you say
he had a black hat on and from my view
all I could see was just a black hat and
black long-sleeve shirt
possibly gloves on uh he had black cargo
pants on but kinds of zippers on the
side in the big puffy pockets he had a
huge about rifle and he had extra ammo
he's coming ready for you coming ready
for something to reload I don't know he
had like magazines i I couldn't clear
what else I saw it was I just softly
dressed exactly the same you're certain
that you saw three men yes look at their
skin color yeah white they look like
they were athletic bills and they
appeared to be tall you're certain that
you saw three men yes they look like
their skin color yeah his white they
look like they were athletic bills and
they appeared to be tall where I was at
right here we see now there was three
white men in military fatigues
taking off what were they driving I was
wear the black black Impala come to you
SUV or like yeah you think that they
might have been the shooter yeah the way
they were driving yeah yeah how many
sons you talk a lot it was a lot it
sounded like the Amika that it was done
like a gun-range two shots going on
crazy over la paga shop which in person
at one one would you turn in thank you
so much
and it just doesn't make sense for for
these two to be able to act like some
kind of Bonnie and Clyde or something
it's just ridiculous it it doesn't add
up and that's not just one person that
said it three different witnesses also
that they were recorded you can watch
them say it on YouTube and that the same
sort of thing has happened elsewhere for
instance the Parrish 20 November 2015
attacks which I also have a book in had
the same situation where witnesses said
that the people who shot up the Billy
keep nightclub were actually a large
white paramilitaries maybe they're the
same ones in San Bernardino I don't know
but they didn't match the description of
the Muslim patsies at all and so yeah we
see this pattern over and over and
somehow were bullied into not talking
about it yeah Wow again if if this was
done by someone who claimed to be Muslim
again Islam condemns actions like this
is has nothing to do with Islam but
we're going to stuff further and saying
that hold on you know the evidence is
showing that this is not like the next
question of the wise is why the
architects and engineers are questioning
why was there this this nano-thermite
found in a dust sample so they're asking
why why would there be this what is
nano-thermite well then i'll thermite is
a mixture it's basically it's a chemical
compound with aluminum that it reacts we
turn stealing to iron melts it so it
reacts at very high temperatures and it
could be used to create something that
would slice through the steel columns to
bring a building down because if you
want a tall building to come down in any
way other than sort of toppling slowly
sideways
you know which would be what would
normally happen if you had an earthquake
or whatever a fire or something if it
were of course fire can't knock down
tall buildings but if it could in any
case nano-thermite can slice columns and
so it could be used in sort of cutter
charges that would slice counts and the
interesting thing is that the dust
samples on 9/11 show not only this
remains of nano-thermite ships but also
iron-rich microspheres which would be
what happens when the iron gets kind of
blown up by these cutter charges their
steel gets blown into iron and it's
sprayed out as a sort of an aerosol
spray and the little tiny bits of molten
iron coalesce as spheres as they go
through the air that turns me to Spears
so tons of that I mean a huge cut
actually a very puzzling ly large
component of the World Trade Center dust
that was tested by Neil Neil heals Herod
a chemistry professor at University of
Copenhagen and Stephen Jones the physics
professor from Brigham Young and many
others showed a lot of that stuff in the
dust so it's actually Edea that the real
mystery is assuming these of samples are
authentic and there's no strong reason
to believe that they aren't the question
would be how can there be that much
especially if the iron rich microspheres
it's as if a tremendous amount of energy
was unleashed to melts or melt and sort
of explode and both melt and explode
simultaneously a very high shockingly
large amount of the steel in the World
Trade Center structure almost more than
you would expect if it was just cutter
charges so even niels harrit is a little
bit puzzle is all there but there's no
way to interpret it innocently so there
really only two possibilities either
somebody has salted those dust samples
which is very unlikely the government
has dust samples so if this weren't true
they could just bring out their samples
and prove it was not true but they
haven't so the other explanation is that
these buildings were explosively
demolished which happens to be provable
in many other ways as well
they're also asking another one of the
wise is why was 160 thousand one hundred
sixty three thousand tons of concrete
pulverized right see the amount of
energy available from gravity as a
building comes down it is that you can
quantify it and you can figure out how
much if it would be used to sort of
break up the building as the slab on top
on the next slide and what we saw with
these twin towers was a very sizable
proportion of the concrete was blasted
out just blasted to smithereens in
pyroclastic cloud formation these are
the kinds of sort of hot slurry clouds
that come out of volcanoes and so a
tremendous amount of energy went into
pulverizing this concrete a sizable
amount of the concrete dust that was
found is like talcum powder sub 100
micron units of concrete so again
massive amounts of energy unleashed far
beyond what you would get from gravity
and if you just look at the pictures of
these twin towers collapse and you're
not collapsing they're exploding look at
it again boom you know you can see these
gigantic 100-ton steel chunks of steel
framing being blasted upwards and
outwards to impale themselves on
neighboring buildings and it's happening
in a perfect symmetry it's been
symmetrical this couldn't possibly
happen from any form of natural collapse
the building is all the only way Billy
could possibly naturally collapse would
be asymmetrically and progressively or
slowly bit by bit chomping but this was
just it's just gone straight down
perfect symmetry obvious demolition next
one in and we're almost at the end of
the six was why were there witnesses
reporting that they heard they saw
explosions they saw and heard explosions
I start exploding the whole lobby
collapse on this area hi horrible oh no
one enough the whole building just
collapsed on it
thank you very slowly yes it was that
was in his plan from definitely
secondaries go from watch the first
comes
he started God qualified sports gonna
pop it out it was I was it was deadly
yeah just like the last man out did you
ever meet the low yeah yeah yeah William
Rodriguez is actually a friend of mine
he you know he couldn't he came to Islam
in Malaysia he ended up accepting this
guy accepted Islam my cell I will
e-reader he's the great hero of 9/11
he's presented in the mainstream media
as the biggest hero of 9/11 who rescued
all sorts of people the guy with the
only key he was a janitor in the North
Tower and he had a key the other couple
of people with keys fled he was the last
guy with a key he led the firemen up
there and they got people out and he was
the last guy out of the North Tower
before it came down he dived under a
fire truck and then they had to dig all
the rubble away to pull him up from the
fire truck they got him out just a
couple of minutes before the fire fire
trucks tires popped from the heat so he
had a real brush with death and that led
him to and accept this lump but he
became you know join the 9/11 truth
movement years later after the 9/11
Commission didn't want to hear what he
had to say and then sealed his testimony
but he had he testified that the explote
the first explosion happened in the
sub-basement below the floor with floor
one and he was on the first floor it's
happened before the plane hit he felt
the impact of the plane maybe you know 7
10 seconds later but the first huge
explosion happened from below blasted up
the floor many people were very
seriously injured and killed in that
explosion down below has happened before
the plane hit so that's one of the most
important parts of his testimony and
he's a great guy
if you ever have a chance get him on
your show you've had firemen you had
many officials who are questioning
because they heard these explosion like
something they described it as a
controlled demolition we just asking
questions can we ask questions well this
is America right yeah actually in a way
we're kind of examples of how the
Americas folks were there's supposed to
be freedom above all freedom of religion
right I mean the people that fled to
this continent we're fleeing religious
persecution in large part so the First
Amendment that insures freedom of
religion go through and freedom of
be stuck in there in the first First
Amendment I mean that's really what this
country is about we're supposed to have
the freedom to think on our own to come
to our own conclusions to investigate
everything and if for example we come up
with a slightly different religious view
from the majority as you and I have we
are supposed to have the full right to
not only do that and it should be
celebrated right and we can talk about
that and likewise when these contested
political events happen we're supposed
to be free to hash that out and
obviously 9/11 has led to a huge
rollback of freedom as well as
Islamophobia so it's really an attack on
the First Amendment and an attack on the
ideas of the founding fathers of the
United States so you know Muslims today
we as Muslims we can be real American
patriots as well as Muslim Patriots by
just standing up for the truth standing
up for the right thing and walking in
the footsteps of the prophets you know
peace to all of them the prophets have
had tough situations it's been hard for
them to tell the truth they've been
persecuted for telling the truth
and yet they stuck by the truth that's a
lot of what prophecy is about so we're
the community with the best-preserved
revelation from the prophets through the
last prophet man we we have to be
standing up for the truth value if we're
not who will absolutely and if you ask
questions and you get a legit answer
like for instance the first question was
why are there 2,500 arcs architects and
engineers wanting a new official
investigation and then someone comes and
says okay because these guys lost their
job they have nothing else to do and
their cetera you get and then let's say
it's something credible or I'm just
giving an example or wider building
trade center come down and then there's
a you know scientific answer something
saying that Oh at the same time the
planes hit they were already getting
ready to take it down they were going to
destroy you could all say oh yeah so is
it simultaneously happened and it's
proven it did it just coincidence right
I'm just giving example but that's not
the case right well ya see ya
or the thermite what's that oh there was
they were doing some experiments in one
of the rooms and then when it came down
these are just remnants of that so you
see that but have you gotten for these
Y's have people gotten
an answer for these you know that yeah
that's a great question and they you
know ever this is I'm not really an
expert in science you know my father was
an engineer he would see if he learned
Germany would have been a PhD engineer
and I grew up dealing with some of the
stuff he did and so I'm not completely
you know I'm not exactly your average
humanities guy as far as completely
ignoring science and engineering but I
am an expert in arguments that's what we
do in the humanities you know we're
going to argue sort of like lawyers
except you know the broader scope and
what I do is I look at the arguments I
did this back when I was a kid with the
JFK assassination
okay here's one group that that says the
President does a pruder film shows the
president's head snapping backwards he's
hit from the front and they say here's
Life magazine photos that publish those
frames in Reverse to make it look like
he was shot from the back so I looked at
okay what does the other side say the
other side says that Oh Life magazine
just made an innocent mistake in reverse
order of the frames and then life mate
and then the official story is that this
magic bullet did an amazing trajectory
to you know hit hit these two guys and
all these different parts of their
bodies turning around in midair all this
so essentially you look at the two sides
of the argument you say well which is a
better argument and it was obvious in
the case of JFK and I could see that
when I was 16 years old and with 9/11 it
turns out to be the same kind of
situation and for people who want to
look at both sides of this argument see
what are the debunkers quote-unquote say
and whether the advocates of the 9/11
truth we would say a really good
resource is the film
it's called September 11th the new Pearl
Harbor it's by an Italian guy in Massimo
mizuka so if you were to feed that into
a search engine September 11th the new
Pearl Harbor you find this series of
films it's what six hours altogether but
you can watch it but I did and he
carefully considers what the different
sides say in these arguments and of
course he concludes as as I had loved I
think the evidence really speaks for
itself you don't have to be an expert in
arguments to figure most of us out
most people who argue this they haven't
really looked at the evidence have they
exactly yeah is he
the whole the way they can get away with
this kind of thing is by scaring people
away from taking a serious look at the
evidence yeah that's amazing and what
and at the end when you when you look at
what this was a catalyst to the mo the
motive behind obviously this doesn't
benefit Islam it doesn't benefit police
this is not good for business
right but is it good for business on the
other end no kidding I mean if you look
at Sherlock Holmes didn't have to we
don't have to bring him in to this deal
I mean what's the motive who gets to
benefit where's the money go
well we even have this document that was
issued exactly one year before 9/11 by
project for a new American Century which
is all of the hardline militaristic
neoconservatives and the document was
called rebuilding America's defenses and
it basically said we need to do
preemptive invasions of the Middle East
and we need to double our military
budget and to do this it's not going to
happen anytime soon without and this is
like a direct quote some cataclysmic and
catalyzing event such as a new Pearl
Harbor
so that was issued one year almost of a
date before 9/11 and they so we have
evidence that this group the people who
dominated the Bush administration with
they were yearning for an event like
9/11 so they could double their military
budget and they could launch these wars
of aggression in the Middle East and a
lot of other people benefit as well of
course all the contractors all the
people who benefit from military money
which is all plundered from the American
taxpayer they made out like bandits the
people who want the government to be a
tyranny that can totally control its
citizens Minds and you know spy on them
and everything those people benefited a
long list of people benefited the people
who are basically committing a very
aggressive invasion and occupation that
the cleansing of the Holy Land in
Palestine that is the hardline Zionists
benefited tremendously probably more
than anyone else so there was a long
list of these folks who benefited from
this and of all the people who didn't
benefit or who lost the single biggest
group would be the Muslims and
especially the Muslims sort of anti
imperialists and anti-zionist the
Muslims who were committed to trying to
free the Muslim world and to develop the
Muslim world and to have an autonomous
Muslim world and to do that we would
have to kick out the riba banks and
corporations that dominate that part of
the world and we would have to make sure
that the local people in the Muslim
world have control of their own
resources and benefit from their own
resources right those are the so-called
anti imperialist and anti Zionist
Muslims I'm one of them and we lost from
9/11 it's been life has been very hard
for us since 9/11 so it's really obvious
who won and who lost so just from from
that on that basis I think and the fact
that every single major American war
since the Mexican war in the 1840s has
been launched by some kind of big public
relations stunt it doesn't take an
expert to see that you're really they
should have to prove that it wasn't a
false flag we shouldn't have to prove
that it was now is that where you just
stay away from does that be someone
jumping into being a conspiracy theorist
because he's trying to figure out how
people conspired because you have all
these departments so is that where you
just ask that your George is asking two
questions and and and or are there some
people because some people can track
their wrap their mind around how could
everyone be in cahoots now every all
these departments everyone working
together to have this unhatched yeah
that's one of the first kinds of you
know skeptical responses we get when we
talk about this well how many people
could have worked together to do this
and wouldn't somebody have talked there
are a lot of possible answers to that
there are cases where huge numbers of
people have worked on secret projects
and nobody's talked classic example is
the Manhattan Project tens of thousands
of people had new classified stuff about
that and nobody talked they built the
nuclear bomb without spilling that
secret and Operation Northwoods
was mentioned earlier a plan to mass
murder Americans in a fake series of
terrorist attacks to launch a war in
Cuba in 1962 was kept completely secret
from 1962 until by very bad luck for the
bad guys one document happened to be
uncovered in the late
so there's another example where a very
nefarious plot that would have involved
huge numbers of people and it was ready
to go in a month was kept completely
secret for all of those decades and one
could cite many many other examples but
the short version is yes they can keep
secrets and the the other thing to point
out is that you know the people that did
9/11 probably thought they were doing
the right thing they have a particular
view of the world and they see
themselves as serving the country in
some cases another country in other
cases and the world I mean there are
people out there who very strongly
believe that the only way to world peace
is a one-world government and that the
best way to get a one-world government
is to strengthen the big central
institutions the banks corporations and
military that are strongest right now
which would be the West and US and West
so by unleashing those forces and trying
to go out and grab a world government
will be imposing world peace and that's
a wonderful glorious project that's one
ideology and then of course as you know
there are many people who don't like
Islam Islam is coming back it was it's
really going strong in the 80s and 90s
and there are people who honestly have
this anti Islam view but they're afraid
of of Islam for many reasons and the
powerful people have really good reasons
to be afraid of it if Islam takes over
no more usery banking running the world
the New World Order banks just syndicate
will be out of business so there are a
lot of powerful folks who clearly have a
good reason to actually think 9/11 would
be a good thing so of course those
people would do it in secret and you
know John Cobb the eminent theologian
wrote about this in the book I edited
called 911 and American Empire this is I
think he's the greatest American
theologian today and many many people
would agree with that and he would he's
in that book 9/11 in the American Empire
saying it looks like an inside job and
saying that the people that did it
probably thought it was the right thing
to do and here's their argument a couple
more questions we're almost out of time
we're at the curtail it in a few what
tell me about the what your experience
that you had with some law law
enforcement
and the when the meeting was over it had
a different respect for you after you
kind of went over some things with it
was it some of the organization or
whatnot well can you talk about that oh
yeah I was wondering about which one you
met because I've run into interesting
conversations with like Homeland
Security and you know I NS and those
people like flown I've been to Iran four
times now in the last three years and so
I would have I was wondering what my
greeting will be like when I get back
but the one you're talking about was
when I was flying home from New York I
had done a talk at a 9/11 truth
anniversary event on the anniversary of
tempered 9/11 temper eleven so I was
flying back home and I was as I was
dozing at the gate I felt a tap on my
shoulder and looked up and there were
three FBI agents flashing their badges
and mr. Barrett would you come with us
we have a few questions for you what's
this about so they dragged me off to a
in Farah Gatien room and on the way the
guy says I've seen you on Fox News you
know okay sits me down and starts out
pulls out a notebook
is this your notebook and I said yeah
that's my notebook I think I left that
on the plane flying into New York
because why is there Arabic in it and I
said well I grabbed that notebook to
write my speech on the plane but I got
into a good conversation with a guy next
to me and I forgot the notebook it's my
old Arabic notebook I learned Arabic you
know years ago could you read me some of
the Arabic so I had to read some Arabic
to him and it was actually lousy Arabic
cuz it was my second year I was trying
to write an essay second year Arabic
student writing an essay anyway so that
long story short this guy suddenly barks
at me are you a terrorist I said no I'm
trying to help you guys catch the real
serious and then they just relax and
well what do you think happened on 9/11
they all get out their pens and
notebooks and so I gave them a similar
you know spiel that I've just given you
they wrote it all down very seriously
didn't look like they disagreed at all
and then when I left the guys shook my
hand in a very friendly way and wished
me good luck getting my job back
so my take on that was that these new
york-based FBI agents know pretty well
that what I'm saying isn't some crazy an
American conspiracy theory it's pretty
much in line with the likely facts of
the case
what's your goal at the end what would
you like to see happen well in you know
best of all possible worlds some you
know viola some some high-level insider
comes forward or something you know
something happens that forces this issue
it forces the case open and I think that
that process could really radically
change things for the better I think a
Truth and Reconciliation Commission a
bit like what happened in South Africa
after the apartheid era would be one way
to go and probably a good way get you
know trade truth if you give us truth
will give you leniency or even amnesty
get that truth out and I think that that
would it would end the current era of
extreme Western and Zionist imperialist
attacks on the world we're looking at it
right now we're facing World War three
with Russia with China with North Korea
not to mention what's going on in Syria
and the Middle East and all of that is
really it's it's aggression coming out
of our side here you know and so we're
sitting here in Chicago USA it's our
responsibility to try to get our side to
tone down before we blow up the world
and what better way to do that than to
force them to admit to the American
people in the people of the world that
9/11 was actually wasn't done by radical
evil Muslim evildoers it was done by the
folks who wanted to launch this
aggressive war on the world and the
result of this I think would be the
United States would turn towards peace
we would take that money that we're
throwing away on the military for no
good purpose right now and use it to
rebuild our infrastructure and to save
the environment solvent world's
environmental problems and I think that
the rest of the world is really ready
for a multipolar peaceful world and
would be very happy if this happened and
would go along with it and then I think
this would last but not least also force
a reasonable settlement to the situation
in occupied Palestine so I think that we
would have innumerable benefits and of
course the Dean of Islam would get a
whole new
look a whole fresh perspective people
would say wow this is what this is not
what we were told
tell us about Islam and your audience
would skyrocket
sella one more one more you know someone
who's genuine sincere and they're
looking to really find out what the
purpose of life is like you were and
they come to evaluate all the different
religions and they like you know the
concept in Islam of God that you only
worship the Creator not the creation the
belief in Jesus is a mighty messenger
and doing good deeds and preparing for
the day of judgment by being the best
neighbor you can be by being the best
human being you can be and this this
pure monotheism that's there but now
there's this propaganda out there the
hate machine is fueled I think over a
quarter of a million dollar annual
business bashing Islam and someone's
affected with this whole thing of
radical Islam radical Muslims you know
Islam is the enemy and without going
into a whole spiel of all of the you
know the the history we went into how do
you in a short you don't get it spending
much time with this person how do you
get them to drop a seat to think beyond
what they've been programmed to the
whole Hollywood you know movie that's
been created for them and they bite on
it how do you get them out of that well
it depends who you're talking to you
know first the first and most important
thing is to see who you're talking to
and kind of communicate on their level
but right now I'm stuck talking to a
bunch of conspiracy theorists
quote-unquote because you know I've gone
down these rabbit holes and so and I'm
writing interesting stuff so people are
reading my stuff and listening to my
radio broadcast and so they're the
people I talk to your people are more or
less aware of these kinds of political
issues but often you know they don't
know much about Islam or their you know
their spiritual side is different so for
those people I do try to emphasize the
other spiritual depth of Islam maybe it
has something to do with the fact that
in Islam we have the first two most sort
of tangible names of God that really
have a meaning you know ar-rahman
ar-rahim and what that comes from the
root for womb and and translated as the
compassionate the merciful whatever the
all-compassionate the armours well it
has to do with the
love the loving mercy and love and
compassion that is the kind of love a
mother feels for her children this is
really interesting so our vision of God
actually is not the masculine vision of
the father and the Son and the Holy
Spirit which is a kind of an all-male
reproduction fantasy it's very massive
on one side and it's missing another
side of the divine
so I talk about this kind of thing to
make people sort of rethink if there are
a lot of people out there now who
realize that the Trinity like most of
the Christians I need don't get the
trinity most of the Christians I meet or
especially the more sort of high end you
know educated people see that there is
this kind of you know religion has been
like to mail whatever macho you know
patriarchal they say that's partly
because there's God the Father metaphor
you know I'm gonna side that maybe Islam
is right maybe that's not the right
metaphor so this is the sort of thing I
talked about to my audience but if I
were just sitting down sort of an
ordinary person I would hope that just
by you know trying to be a good example
a good neighbor an honest person
speaking the truth as I see it friendly
and relatively non judgmental you know I
I don't want to be judging on my
non-muslim neighbors and friends too
much for the sum of their things that I
would like to see them ultimately change
but just just actually you know be
having friendly relations with
non-muslims and and setting a good
example that's how Islam spread so fast
across so much of the world was by
people being pious and decent and
honorable and honest merchants that's
that's ultimately the bottom-line thing
we have to do is to change ourselves we
can't change the world until we change
ourselves yeah that's the Islam that
people don't get to hear about they
don't get to see or read about with all
of the negative stereotypes propaganda
is out there how can people get a hold
of you they won't invite you to a
university to give a talk to read some
of your stuff I'm gonna get in contact
with you
well they can find me through my website
which is truth jihad com
remember the best jihad is a word of
truth flung in the face of a tyrant so
that's my idea we shouldn't time for
bloodshed is over the weapons are too
big
nasty you can't fight wars according to
Islamic rules very well anymore so we
need to wage jihad of the tongue speak
the truth speak truth to power so that's
that's the truth jihad concept the
website is truth jihad calm that's where
people can get in contact with you all
your reading material and yeah you can
find everything for that thank you very
much thank you very thank you very much
now remember this important point if all
the Muslims were drinking alcohol doing
drugs going to nightclubs fornicating
gambling well that mean Islam allowed it
no because Islam is clear on the issue
the same way if a Muslim or a group of
Muslims brings harm to an innocent human
being or human beings Islam condemns it
we condemn it and Muslims as you know by
now have become professional condemned
errs evil acts like 9/11 which was a
catalyst for the war on Islam that
doesn't have any justification in Islam
but has brought much havoc and harm to
Muslims in Islam we're the ones
suffering the most from it but now
critical thinkers scientists architects
engineers are asking the six why
questions like what we discussed on the
show and more coming out after
investigating the issue but why is there
right to free speech which is not
hate-filled bigoted speech like what
many of the Islamophobes
use that incites violence in many cases
but it's their critical questions being
asked and people ask them like dr. Kevin
are fired and can't get a job because
they're being censored this is is that
free speech hate while hateful speech
which in many cases like I said incites
violence is it's okay but critical
questions like to six questions that we
covered today the why questions you lose
your job is that right let's talk about
it respectfully leave your thoughts
in the comments below and don't forget
to subscribe
much peace of love so moms